[音楽]
ん
ルーンバムとこぼしちゃった
よ
[音楽]
なぜだ
亀田
ユーチューバー
1丁型城見台タイガー
me今日はパティですはい
パティ店へへっうっ800万円を至ります
うっ後すぎや
良い一教アティパンツってますねみんな他
に好きなんですね
ブーバーさーん読んで行っの
パティと思います
[拍手]
ウードゥー宴会イカロス日に行きゃいい
けどっっ路線へへっ
掴み取り
山なかったなと
思いましてプレ変更させていただきますよ
はい
聞かれさんは本当にやらただの事故
3組だったんだよのルールなしでやらせて
いただいたんですけどもこれもうまつり
前夜祭なんてちょっと普通の湯中バター
そんな簡単に5000万円つになれども
化けてしまいましたら感覚が破産しますね
果たします私があるのでいろいろちょっと
スタッフのカルト微調整させていただき
ましていい感じに設けられるかボケられ
ないかみたいなルールを作らせていただき
ましたこれではなくですね今回なんと
こちらでございますね王棒みたいな感じ
これをを上からウィーンできた時にバット
当然離さずにガッツとさせていただいて
そのままって戻って言ってパソコに落とせ
だ君だけ賞金になるという
なっておりますなるほど参加料金なんです
けども
大事だなぁ
20万円に行かせていただきます20万
以上ちょっと出棺プラスになりますねー
さんが来たんですけどもう熱海の方で土砂
災害があったのでそちらに記述させて
いただきます
はい
バッハ僕がお金配りよってたんですかね
つまりそういうことですね楽しんでいきま
しょーう
では最初のされんじゃーこの方ですね
どうぞ
[拍手]
gooみずどりボンドの簡単ですよろしく
お願いしまーす
ねーっていうわけで患者さん早速今日
はい
5ピンの深み取りでございます
pr 何してる
俺も思った大学ので俺も思ったら
あてにビールなんですけどはい傘下に置き
20万円
持ってきたんはっはっはすごいアンテナ
なんかでそれじゃああー
あんな様当然です木ごまどうぞ
目指せ
50万円を聞くれましたこれすごいん海の
ございますね俺どうしようこれでよ100
とか取ったら
素直に喜ぶがポーラーですしね
シュミレーションした時は30万前後
くらいですかねえとはそんなもんですね
こんな友いろんなクリエイターが来ます
から
大受が整ったようです
[音楽]
は緊張する俺がっていう
そう子連れよろしいでしょうかはい行き
まー
[拍手]
car
あとから指示だった
さぁ始まりました簡単なチャレンジで
ございます操作するのは私肇社長
あんたが上がって終わってよく
あんまりお金が少ないアミューズがないの
で考えら伊藤さんから軽く取るかなって
いうイメージしてますさあ止まった
言わなかった
何の時間だったのでしょう
思います
最後に出しましたにゃーんスライドして
いく除算あっち億円の空母を近づいていき
ます
カンター水玉リボンとトミーが急死して
いるなんか彼は何を持っています空を飛ん
でいるのか
いいところって
タイミングで脅されます
一回目だから俺もちょっと感覚がわから
ないのでもお試し感覚でやってるんです
けども
あのリハーサルとかやっぱりのテストとか
テストとかやった感じは20万円前後の
旅館ですこの大きさこのお盆だとそれが
ないさあ場所が決まったカンタが降りる
なってきますこれ
wi-fi
強いどれだけ使うかんだよく兵があまり
つか願っています
今
[音楽]
グリーン
しっかりと奥まで奥まで村内9そんなに
これ
そんなぐっあやばいなこれ
ああいうやばいいいてっかんだらしくの
企画案たらしくないキーやっていいかも
しれないと言いながら買って行くああ
ani
ここから私の仕事は落とすことですパワー
スライドして
はぁっ一枚落ちていくが1枚は御山
岩ああ牧場主と寄ったまた一枚落ちた
ただかなりああ凄い凄いこれこんな声出す
んだかんだわねぇ
行いかあっあーっ
落ちます今下されていきます
10日目5時でしたあれ
だがもう落ちなそうな位置まで下がってき
ていますそのままお金をしっかりと
はいあっなぜいっ
[音楽]
ブーバーんっ
ブーブーどんどん難しくれ
都塚7なもの使っ
てみて
まあおかしいよねパットに
100万じゃ効かないきゃず3中マンズ
聞かないですね
と数えてみます
[音楽]
ちょっとペースにスパイがございまし
たーーーこれぞと思いました2血管ゲーム
ですねうードゥやっぱ着一さんの
チャンネルに出るんだったら全力であろう
まあそうなっちゃうよねいやああああぬー
んですけども獲得金額でございますプレ
1万円のブワッおっ
ブーバー今
ヌーんです簡単年初の記録やという思い
千円札
66万円
5000円札
79枚ん
1番札
180ヤード
227万1000円でございまーす
rar
やっぱんでしたねよく6ねー
やっぱり動画に使いたいといいねぇー
これはやっぱさすがに youtube が
盛り上がるんだったらここ何を言った場合
はもう全力で支えます同然ございまし
たーーー
またちょっとお願いします嫌ですよ
葛藤する
これはもう来た目ですやばいよねやば金額
は買えないです参加料がを変えると
ちょっと今後の人が可哀想になってくるん
で勤務がもいちいちなんですけどもゲーム
の世界にもあるかもですけどアップデート
強いキャラは下方修正税弱いキャラは情報
終点食べるのでこのゲームをダンタンと
難しくなっていますゲームバランスを調整
するということですそれ引き続き楽しんで
やっていきましょう
さあやってまいりました今回のゲストは
こちらの方ですどうぞ
ようこそゲストも余裕ですよろしくお願い
します誰か誰か誰か現場で行ったでは元気
ですよ
自衛隊さんちなみにお金は吹きですかまー
すきー
場所をご覧くださいこちら
あったところ1億円のプールでございませ
ん
今回いう他にははい1億円の深緑
チャレンジ挑戦した目通り違うんですよ
いいんですかですが参加了的に出入りと
20万円ほど経っ日は米まあまあよって
多分一さんが僕身長負けないですけどては
結構
ビッカーじゃあやってるんですけどからに
まで届く一人道から3まで届くんですね
もうそこらへんを地の利を生かし一
間
[音楽]
ブーブーを使ってへ挑戦していただきたい
と思います800関係ないああああ
ヌーしますちゃんって流産準備ができたと
いうことで入っにょ強くを提供します
やっぱり持って帰るぞ
ます遊佐さん入っ
版やーで浮いているときは気をつけて
くださいね
ご覧ください肇社長の顔もうお金は失い
たくない一壁山でただでさえ5000万円
うちになっている肇社長にこれ以上お金を
上げる余地はない
んじゃないん
もよろしいでしょうか
さあいう打算今始まりました挑戦です
実はあったことがこれ4回目ぐらいなんで
あの
改正は少ないんですけども意外と仲良い
です
上っていきます入荷選手色
っぽ動いている高いと高いとこ行っている
あの聞いた竿はたという裕太さん酵素恐怖
症らしいですがしっかりとスライドすって
プールの上まで向かっていきます
はっ速度が速いそれから
ブーツ速度がやや早い
しづを出してちょっとましたとと指示を
出しています今たどり着いた
ここらへんなという自然のもと下ろして
いきます
本当に苦手そうだなのでかっ
enter アーマーせた場所はそれが
勘違いターンでも止まらないんハーイは
プールに着水した
そのままアーサーイン早く作っ
うーんね雑早かった
ちょっとだけでした
はここで弾みさと優しさが出てしまった
もう1回行ってみますかこのままいけば
もっと20万以下たた可能性があるが
ファーンなんかすごい角度で腕だけ入って
を取りすぎだよ
メダル取りすぎだよそれ
弾みで超優しいでそこは
倉庫は優しさが出てしまったただここから
が
じゃん
voodoo しかーしますこれ俺のかに
いっ
が出来ました+ライドで元の位置に戻って
いきます
止まって戻って進まれく
を振ったい左右に振っをとっていく作戦
すごい系武力だ全然憶えが落ちない
本当に怖がっているのでそうさんを通して
あげましょう
さらに細かい醤油んだあああ
あったんだ
ミッチがやや悪いかこれは
大量の風がドロップ
それも大きい残りの場でしかに今入れまし
たお助けじゃねぇー
[拍手]
ん
dare
わー
全然 ok な顔するから
で追われて言えばなこういったんじゃない
ですか
ちょっと数えますはい
ありがとうございまーちょっと待って以下
があるとこれどっちだがゆたさんが作られ
た凍っになりますユーザ結界気配
集計結果
千円札が16ない敗を守った
5000円札が4枚ん
1万円札があっ
66ない oko 4
敗ましたあーー
ヌーろっきゅあにょぷあ
[笑い]
[拍手]
懐っこいて立っこそなんて本当にいたバズ
キルア
シックスナインおめでとうございますこの
動画土ふまずヤバ気になっちゃうんです次
のチャレンジャーでさらに難しくなるかも
しれませんまた次回お会いしましょう
4 r2回生なので
もうあてやろう
白中8永松ねー
ロレーヌあああああ
はぁ
さっき豪快ばついて本当に商売10
初めて核は仕事なんねぇいいねぇいいと
ああああ
goo
わあああああ
あっ
[音楽]
はぁ
し